hablamos ahora de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france24 rosa pérez
masdéu conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez
feliz mañana de martes a más abril
entonces esta revista de prensa rosa
haciendo el seguimiento un tema que
abordamos hace ya algunos días en esta
misma sección la masacre de calamón en
el sur de damasco la capital de siria
the gardian publicó que algunas de las
víctimas de la matanza han sido
identificadas y titula el artículo de la
siguiente manera corría de una manera
familiar dolor mientras las familias
identifican a las víctimas de tal amor
el texto del corresponsal de garden en
oriente medio' martin chulov buenos días
raúl exactamente si te parece recordemos
un poco de qué se trata pues de qué se
tratan estos hechos no como decía se fue
una matanza de civiles perpetrada por un
combatiente de una milicia pro asad y
por un miembro de la inteligencia
militar siria que fue identificado como
ahmed yusef los hechos tuvieron lugar en
2013 en el suburbio sur de damasco
llamado tada mont bien pues como
decíamos no es así es que reveló the
gardian en el 26 de abril de este mismo
año pues ya empiezan a tener sus
repercusiones solamente para indicar que
aquellos que quieran pues conocer más a
fondo y recordar un poco de qué van
estos hechos que podrían ser potenciales
a crímenes de guerra pueden leer la
pieza que sacó de garcía en el 26 de
abril y también el artículo en new line
donde dos investigadores de países bajos
guru mit hongos y ansar youth explican
cómo llegaron a identificar el autor de
la masacre uno de los autores porque el
otro está fallecido pero digamos en
estas consecuencias de las que hablamos
como decías algunos familiares tras ver
estas imágenes han podido identificar
algunos de sus seres queridos pues que
mueren bueno cómo se ve cómo mueren
directamente en este vídeo tal y como
explica the gardian algunos habían
estudiado el vídeo cuadro por cuadro
para identificar a su ser querido otros
supieron en un instante que uno de los
hombres asesinados en la masacre de
tamón era miembro de su familia que
había desaparecido hace nueve largos
años y entre los testigos que aparecen
citados en este texto está el de los
familiares de chillán particularmente su
padre digo dice mi amigo que vive en los
países bajos me envió este vídeo lo vi
una dos tres veces y note que uno de
ellos corría de una manera familiar y
era mi hijo también su madre dice me
esperaba de todo que hubiera perdido un
ojo que lo hubieran torturado pero no
esto bueno raúl al menos familias que ya
saben no pues qué ha pasado con sus
seres desaparecidos porque no hay mayor
angustia no y claro pues mentalmente
también pues saber dónde está el cuerpo
de esa persona quería y no quedar en
como en el limbo en hacer un duelo
debido en estos casos no rosa acta mente
bueno cambiamos ahora determinamos a
francia donde el periodismo político
gira en torno a las inminentes
elecciones legislativas que vamos a
presenciar el próximo mes de junio rosa
vamos a ver un extracto al programa de
la televisión pública france franck que
se ha hecho viral porque bueno pues como
dices no ya a francia se encara esta sal
isla tibás y tienen lugar en las
televisiones pues debates electorales
donde los distintos representantes de
cada partido contrastan un poco sus
programas discute etcétera y
particularmente en un programa de
françois región de una de las
televisiones de las televisiones
públicas la candidata de agrupación
nacional jose emblema nacional en
francés el partido encabezado por martín
lópez se queda digamos en blanco cuando
le preguntan por los servicios por sus
propuestas en términos de servicios
públicos se trata de la candidata
melanie fuerte que es el aspirante a
ocupar un escaño del departamento de co2
en el noreste de francia y la periodista
que le hace la pregunta se llama él sabe
son si te parece veamos el extracto de
este programa saber
cuáles son políticas sobre esto es decir
cuáles son política en materia de
servicios públicos qué es lo que ustedes
quieren en agrupación nacional hago
referencia a lo que se acaba de comentar
delante suyo no es una pregunta trampa
sino acaba de entender la pregunta que
más bien depende que el servicio público
quiere hoy en francia
lo siento podríamos cortar esta parte
realmente no comprendo la pregunta y no
podemos cortarlas no es posible
bueno este fragmento ha sido muy
comentado tanto en redes sociales como
en distintos medios de comunicación un
poco con la duda de si realmente la
señorita fortis se queda en blanco o si
realmente no quiere revelar el programa
esté un poco de desmantelar los
servicios públicos que tiene agrupación
nacional en todo caso y bien mal para
quedó porque posee una política en temas
de qué va a hacer con esto tan delicado
pues evidentemente no se puede quedar
callada no rosa pero bueno cerramos con
un evento periodístico esperado
anualmente por la profesión por nosotros
los periodistas bueno todo el mundo ya
la verdad se ha hecho muy popular la
universidad de columbia en mayor y su
público jugar los galardonados con el
premio pulitzer este 2022 exactamente y
es que estos premios pulitzer pues
tienen categorías de ficción pero
también de no ficción y entre los
premios periodísticos pues hay en la
periodismo de 'breaking news' la
cobertura de 'breaking news' periodismo
de investigación local internacional
fotografía audio pero hemos querido
destacar en la medio que ha sido
galardonado por su rol en términos de
servicio público porque al final de esto
va a nuestra profesión y se trata del
washington post por su cobertura y
reconstrucción del asalto al capitolio y
también destacar que la mención especial
ha sido para los periodistas de ucrania
raúl pues por su coraje a la cubrir esta
guerra frente a la inmigración rusa y
como anécdota buena curiosidad el año
pasado de hecho esta mención especial
fue para darle la frase tsjr quien filmó
el asesinato de georges floyd ese vídeo
que tantas repercusiones tuvo a nivel
mundial muchas gracias por toda la
información no fue mañana con más de
revista de prensa saludamos a nuestro
primer invitado del día